et comment va ta petite amie oh elle est
géniale elle l'est vraiment elle est absolument
fantastique
et est-ce que tu prévois de la
rencontrer à tout moment
oh elle n'arrête pas de me demander là-bas mais
mais qu'est-ce que tu lui envoies depuis
plus d'un an maintenant qu'est-ce que tu attends
rien c'est juste que tu n'es pas sûr à 100%
qu'elle est en fait une femme bien sûr
je suis sûr qu'elle l'est
je suis absolument sûr qu'elle
doit définitivement avoir raison laissez-moi vous montrer ce texte
qu'elle m'a envoyé l'autre soir d'
accord c'est  comme 11 heures,
elle dit que le signal sur ce téléphone est une
merde totale, c'est que le service
fonctionne réellement, le téléphone lui-même ne devrait
vraiment pas être plus de trois ou quatre
pièces sous garantie bien sûr, je vais
vous dire ce que j'étais sur le point de  scum down
tu me donnes une chute ça marche et je ne
logerai pas celui-ci dans ton cul ne reçois pas
beaucoup de signal là-haut Oh
j'ai presque oublié ouais Santé j'ai pris la liberté
pendant que tu te recroquevillais
courageusement  dans le dos à la
liberté de faire  un dimanche matin à
la gare de Port Talbot, votre petit ami est
à 9h15 de Cardiff, vous avez marché,
ce n'est pas facile de perdre votre virginité avec
quelqu'un à 50 miles de là, alors vous l'avez invitée
ici, vous l'avez fait pour autant qu'elle sache Jésus
fraude et elle ressemble à Cameron Diaz  oh
comme c'est terrible dans quel
univers tu lui as dit que tu ressemblais à quelqu'un de
célèbre aussi un peu ouais